wow nous l'avons fait nous sommes à mi-chemin nous y sommes
juste
donnez-vous essayer de vous pousser d'accord c'est
juste ici d'
accord
donc d'accord bon bon
facile s'il vous plaît d'accord je n'ai pas je
veux juste une sorte de pagaie
pourquoi avez-vous  laisse-nous
nathan
pourquoi m'as-tu laissé moi et maman
regarde j'ai beaucoup voyagé ma chérie et
ta mère et moi
ce n'est pas facile uh il
n'y a pas de bonne réponse chéri d'
accord tu as une autre famille non
non ma chérie je ne suis pas venu
tu en as une autre  la famille est ce que c'est
avez-vous une autre
fille parfaite quelque part m'avez-vous vu et
ne voulez-vous pas que je sois comme ça n'est pas ça